clay said one of the most interesting
things to me when have you ever walked
into the facility and being like man
what's Dey on today because we all have
our days right like I'm sure there's
some days Klay walk in and be like Dre
on some today it's some days we
all walk in and be like man what is
coach on today I don't know what the
worst of decky was always smart super
smart smart as hell joyful just bring
the like great energy stay out the way
but like you feel his presence and he up
to you he shake your hand hug you smile
what's up BR
laugh like like that's what you got from
Dey you couple all of that with the most
brilliant basketball mind sh a special
presence we lost s a great incredible
person great man